new research shows mass shooters have a
lot in common the findings could be used
to help prevent future attacks the
violence project has studied every u.s.
mass shooting since 1966 its database
which is not publicly available yet
includes 160 mass shooters who have
killed four or more people in a public
place nearly all were male and the
average age was 34 years old
the study found most shooters shared
common traits like experiencing
childhood trauma the researchers also
learned these shootings are socially
contagious psychologist Jillian Peterson
is co-founder of the violence project
its findings will be published later in
a book and she joins us now Jillian good
morning good morning let me start with
this idea of childhood trauma because
people hear that right away and say red
flag red flag what did you find out
though about childhood trauma and these
mass shooters so we found that it's
really a slow build over time so you do
see intense childhood trauma things like
parental suicide serious physical and
sexual abuse heavy bullying but then
that builds over time you add in mental
health concerns you add in a real crisis
point and then access to this script for
this form of violence and the means to
carry it out and so we do see these
common factors but of course the
majority of people who experience
childhood trauma this is not how it
turns out nearly every mass shooter that
you studied suffered an identifiable
crisis you say before the shooting yeah
and that's something we've been really
interested in in terms of prevention so
in the days weeks or months before the
shooting there's a market change in
behavior and it's typically a suicidal
crisis so about 80% we could identify
were actively suicidal before they did
this and these really are suicides in
essence their horrific but the shooter
typically dies and so that change in
behavior people leak their plans a 78%
link to their plans ahead of time so
people knew so a that if they're 8 out
of 10 gave a warning in effect yes a
very clear warning and so if we can
train people to be thinking about those
signs of a crisis and to also not only
recognize them but know what to do with
those warning signs know who to report
to know what intervention strategies are
in place in their work
places or their schools or their
churches that's something we're really
thinking about in terms of prevention
you've also researched mass shooters 200
mass shooters who did not successfully
follow through with their plan
thankfully what did you take away from
that and what else can people you know
who are watching this program learn from
again that idea of attempting to do
something but they were not able to and
I think it also probably speaks to those
who step forward and may have said
something yeah you do find a lot of
stories of people who were thinking
about doing this we're in a really dark
place had seen others do this we're
getting radicalized online were
gathering weapons but someone stepped in
and what is kind of inspiring is
oftentimes it actually doesn't take that
much to get someone through that crisis
point certainly long-term intervention
takes a lot but just getting someone
through that moment it can just be
someone stepping in and saying are you
okay let's reach out is there an easy
way though you think about it how do you
know when it's somebody just spouting
out anger venting maybe just having a
angrier side and when it is something
that you need to step in on you don't
know but there's minds that are
different anything that people can draw
on not necessarily but what we're
thinking is crisis intervention
de-escalation suicide prevention those
are skills that are going to be helpful
in many situations if someone's just
angry if someone is feeling suicidal if
someone's just going through a hard time
not only a mass shooting it's it'll be
helpful in general but we also think it
would help in terms of mass violence
two of them were alarming words in your
report are the socially contagious words
yeah that I mean we've seen that it
appears it would appear this past
weekend we have we've actually had three
incidents in what four or five days yeah
these trigger other attacks don't think
they do so we did find that these are
socially contagious perpetrators study
other perpetrators and when one happens
the most concerning period of time is
the week after because there tends to be
more yeah
people read about it online they see the
notoriety that people get they watch
these manifestos get spread johnmiller
with the New York Police Department who
is here yesterday said it's not people
who suddenly plan an attack it's people
who've been thinking about it who
suddenly decide now is the time to do it
exactly yes who become inspired if well
by seeing another one play out what
systems should schools should churches
have in place to try and have a system
where people feel comfortable reporting
it whether it is something major or
minor but just so there's a place where
this information is going whether you
know to build a profile of someone who
people need to sort of be on the lookout
for so we in schools have been talking
about and care teams
so rather than threat assessment teams
which feels like you know someone's a
threat and I need to report it and
they're gonna get in trouble and the
police are going to get called and I
think people get scared to report things
because they don't want to get people in
trouble get them fired but if we can
report to a group of people who know
resources and can connect people and
approach it in a different way saying
are you okay
what can we do to help you that gives it
a different flavor and I think people
would be more likely to reach out
Julianne you mentioned mental illness
and President Trump made a point of
mental mentioning mental illness
yesterday how significant a role does
mental illness play in this so you do
find mental health concerns certainly in
the vast majority of mass shooters but
it's important that mental illness and
violence you're not more likely to
commit violence if you're mentally oh
you're actually less likely to commit
violence if you have a mental illness
you're more likely to be a victim what
we see is these are complicated pathways
and they it's childhood trauma and
mental health and bullying and other
stress factors and you see this low
build over time they're complex pathways
so picking out any one piece doesn't
work one of the stress factors that was
also mentioned is video games is that a
real factor you know we did code video
games and we are looking at that it's a
bigger factor in the younger school
shooters but it's not it's not the
majority or it's not an overwhelming
sort of piece that we're seeing it's you
when you say it's a bigger factor among
them it's what contribution if anything
does it make so again I think it's one
piece of this puzzle right so we have
you know there's some case studies where
you see someone who's been in a lot of
first-person violent video games
and they kind of take that into the
shooting it's it's sort of that script
for violence right you're practicing
that script and so it becomes more
normalized some very interesting
information there julian peterson thanks
so much for being with us this morning
thanks so much for having